This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. If you were to paint a portrait of the inner workings of your mind, what would it look like? Maybe you would use bright splashes of color to represent your most intense emotions, shades of grey to reflect the complexity and nuance of your thoughts. Swirls and spirals to express the moments when you are lost in rumination. No one else could paint this picture. You know yourself better than anyone else and you are the one most attuned to your inner rhythms, your fears and insecurities, your hopes and
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。如果你要为自己内心的运作方式画一幅肖像，它会是什么样子的？也许你会用鲜艳的色彩泼墨来表达你最强烈的情绪，用灰色调来反映你思想的复杂性和细微差别。用旋转和涡流来表达你陷入沉思的时刻。没有人能画出这幅画。你比任何人都更了解自己，你也最能契合自己内心的节奏、恐惧、不安、希望和
dreams. Yet, even though we may feel we are acutely aware of every corner of our mental landscapes, it turns out many aspects of our minds are hidden from us. It's almost like if you imagine a fork in the road and it just goes two different ways, there are just two different paths here. There's the path that we use for self-judgment
梦想。然而，尽管我们可能会觉得对精神世界的每一个角落都有敏锐的觉察，但事实证明，我们大脑的许多方面对我们来说是隐藏的。这就好像，如果你想象道路上的一个分叉口，它只是通往两个不同的方向，这里只有两条不同的路径。一条是我们用于自我判断的路径
and there's the path that we use for self-judgment, and there's the path that we use for judging others. And in my view, the path that we use for judging others is we look at their actions. The path that we use for judging ourselves is we look inwards. This week on Hidden Brain, we bring you the third installment of our Mind Reading 2.0 series.
，另一条是我们用于自我判断的路径，还有一条是我们用于判断他人的路径。在我看来，我们用来判断他人的路径是观察他们的行动。我们用来判断自己的路径是向内看。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们为您带来“读心术2.0”系列的第三部分。
In previous episodes, we explored how we read other people's intentions and the social illusions that pervade everyday interpersonal relationships. Today, in a favorite episode from 2020, we look at one of the most bewildering aspects of how we read minds. In this case, our own. On a daily basis, all of us evaluate others. We think about the claims of people who want to sell us something, we gauge the ideas of colleagues, we assess friends and family. We also regularly look into our own hearts and minds,
在之前的节目中，我们探讨了我们如何解读他人的意图，以及充斥在日常人际关系中的社会幻觉。今天，在2020年的一期备受欢迎的节目中，我们将探讨我们解读思维方式时最令人迷惑的方面之一。具体来说，是我们自己的思维。每天，我们所有人都在评估他人。我们思考那些想向我们推销东西的人的话，我们衡量同事的想法，我们评估朋友和家人。我们还经常审视自己的内心和思想，
we evaluate ourselves. At Princeton University, psychologist Emily Pronen has studied why our minds come to very different conclusions about ourselves and others. Emily Pronen, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Sean Carr. So a few years ago, Emily, you conducted an experiment where you brought volunteers into a lab and you told them about a range of different biases, you know, biases like the halo effect where, you know, you see someone who's very beautiful and you assume this person must also be very intelligent or a bias like confirmation bias where we go looking for information that supports our pre-existing
我们评估自己。在普林斯顿大学，心理学家艾米莉·普罗宁研究了为什么我们的大脑会对我们自己和他人得出截然不同的结论。艾米莉·普罗宁，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。那么几年前，艾米莉，你做过一个实验，你把志愿者请进实验室，告诉他们一系列不同的偏见，你知道，比如光环效应这样的偏见，就是你看到一个非常漂亮的人，你就认为这个人一定也非常聪明；或者像确认偏见这样的偏见，我们会去寻找支持我们既有
views. And you did something very interesting. You asked the volunteers whether they thought that they would fall prey to these biases. What did they tell you? We had students in a class so that they kind of all knew each other from being in the class together. And what we did is we described each bias just in a few so that they kind of all knew each other from being in the class together. And what we did is we described each bias just in a few sentences. We didn't use the word bias. We didn't want to make it sound like a negative thing so that people would say, that's bad. I don't do that. We just described it in neutral terms.
观点的的信息。你做了一件非常有趣的事。你问志愿者，他们是否认为自己会沦为这些偏见的受害者。他们对你说了什么？我们当时有一班学生，他们因为一起上课而互相认识。我们所做的是，用短短几句话描述每种偏见，这样他们因为一起上课而互相认识。我们所做的是，用短短几句话描述每种偏见，
Sometimes people do this. Do you do this? And what we found is that people said, oh gee, other people do do that. You know, that's so great. You put that into words like that. I see that all the time. But me, I know I don't really do that. So what happened was people recognized the bias as something that people do,
。我们没有使用“偏见”这个词。我们不想把它说成是一件消极的事情，免得人们说：“这不好，我才不那样做。”我们只是用中性的词汇来描述它。有时人们会这样做。你会这样做吗？我们发现人们会说：“哦天哪，别人确实会那样做。你知道，你把话说得太透彻了。我经常看到这种事。但至于我，我知道我其实不那样做。”所以结果是，人们认为偏见是别人会做的事，
and they attributed it to other people, but they thought that they did it quite a bit less. And the same thing happens in so many different domains. If you asked me, do you evaluate the news fairly? Are you a good judge of policy? I'll tell you, of course I am, but I can see lots of biases in the people around me. Emily, you call this the bias blind spot.
，并将其归咎于他人，但他们认为自己犯这种错误的几率要小得多。在许多不同的领域，同样的事情也会发生。如果你问我：“你对新闻的评价公正吗？你对政策的判断力好吗？”我会告诉你：“当然是的，但我能看到周围人身上有很多偏见。”艾米莉，你把这称为偏见盲点。
What do you mean by the term? The reason why I came to call it a bias blind spot is that a blind spot refers to a situation where you can see something sort of all around you except in one place. And so the blind spot is seeing the bias in yourself because it turns out that people could readily recognize these biases all around them. Let's look at some specific domains where the bias blind spot affects us. When it comes to ethics, we're all quick to see conflicts of interest in other people, but slow to see it when it comes to ourselves.
你这个词是什么意思？我之所以把这称为偏见盲点，是因为盲点指的是这样一种情况：你可以看到周围的某种东西，却唯独在一个地方看不到。所以，盲点就是看不到自己身上的偏见，因为事实证明，人们可以很容易地认出周围存在的这些偏见。让我们来看看偏见盲点影响我们的几个具体领域。在道德方面，我们都急于看到别人的利益冲突，却很难察觉到我们自己的利益冲突。
It's such a beautiful example. So you know, doctors and gifts from the pharmaceutical industry. So people have studied this. And doctors will say, I'm not influenced by gifts. And oftentimes the gifts are small, right? They're like, you have a Pfizer pen. Sometimes the gifts are rather large. Like, we'd love to hear you come and give a talk
这是一个非常美好的例子。你知道，医生和制药行业的礼品。人们对此进行过研究。医生会说：“我不会受礼品的影响。”通常礼品都很小，对吧？比如，你有一支辉瑞的笔。有时礼品相当丰厚。比如：“我们希望你能来做个关于你的研究的演讲，
on your research, you know, in the Caribbean, you know, we'll fly you over there, you know, in a private jet and to give your talk. And I credit to the medical industry that I think, you know, they have really worked on trying to root this out because they recognized it as a problem. So there's no longer free lunches for residents every day, you know, sponsored by various drug companies as far as I understand. But the point being that doctors said that they were not influenced by these gifts, but that other doctors were. So it's a perfect example of a conflict of interest not being recognized in self but seen in others.
你知道，在加勒比海，你知道，我们会用私人飞机把你接过去，你知道，去做你的演讲。”我赞赏医疗行业的一点是，我认为，你知道，他们确实在努力根除这种现象，因为他们认识到这是一个问题。据我所知，现在住院医师们不再每天都有由各大制药公司赞助的免费午餐了。但关键是，医生们说他们没有受到这些礼品的影响，但其他医生受影响了。这是一个完美的例子，说明利益冲突在自己身上无法被识别，但在别人身上却能看到。
The bias blind spot also affects how we think we are affected by marketing and how we think others are affected by marketing. I want to play you a clip for an ad that I recently came by. GLH means great looking hair. Just spray GLH on and it instantly covers your ball spot, leaving you with great looking hair. GLA says not a paint or a cover-up. It's an amazing powder that cleans to the tiniest hairs on your head. Order GLA now for only a little bit more. So that was an ad for spray on hair.
偏见盲点还影响我们认为自己如何受营销影响，以及我们认为别人如何受营销影响。我想放一段我最近偶然听到的一则广告的剪辑。GLH的意思是头发看起来很棒。只需喷上GLH，它就能立即遮盖你的秃斑，让你拥有看起来很棒的头发。GLA说这不是油漆或遮盖物。这是一种神奇的粉末，能附着在你头上最细小的头发上。现在订购GLA只需多花一点钱。所以那是一个喷雾头发的广告。
Now, I don't think I'm influenced by advertising, whether that's commercial advertising or political advertising, but I think other people are quite vulnerable to such persuasion. Yeah, there's a phenomenon called the third person effect whereby people think that persuasive attempts have more of an impact on other people than themselves. So they say, oh, commercials, political ads, those things, I'm sort of immune to them. They don't influence me. Whereas people recognize it's a whole industry. It's influencing other people, but we see others as more susceptible to these influences than ourselves. Yeah. How does this work in politics? When we evaluate our political opponents,
现在，我认为自己不会受到广告的影响，无论是商业广告还是政治广告，但我认为其他人很容易受到这种说服的影响。是的，有一种现象叫做第三人称效应，即人们认为说服性尝试对其他人的影响比对自己更大。所以他们会说：“哦，商业广告、政治广告那些东西，我对它们某种程度上有免疫力。它们不会影响我。”然而人们认识到这是一个完整的行业。它在影响着其他人，但我们认为其他人比我们更容易受到这些影响。是的。这在政治中是如何运作的？当我们评估我们的政治对手时，
how does this bias sort of play out in our evaluations both of people on our side and people on the other side? Yeah, so that's a great question. And obviously, we've all been thinking about it a lot recently. So I think there's a lot of things that are going on. One is, what do I believe are the roots of my political opinions and political beliefs? And people will swear that the roots of their political beliefs are just an irrational analysis of the issue, right? So I take the positions I do because those are the correct positions. If you analyze the issues, if you analyze the state of the country, if you think about what's best for the nation, these are the correct positions. But they don't view the, that as being the root to the positions of those on the other side. So the other side is influenced by ideology, by self-interest, by prejudice, whatever it is.
这种偏见在多大程度上影响了我们对本方人员和对方人员的评估？是的，这是一个很好的问题。显然，我们最近都在思考这个问题。所以我认为有很多事情正在发生。一是，我认为我的政治观点和政治信念的根源是什么？人们会发誓，他们政治信念的根源只是一种对问题的理性分析，对吧？所以我持这些立场，因为这些是正确的立场。如果你分析这些问题，如果你分析国家的现状，如果你考虑什么对国家最好，这些就是正确的立场。但他们不认为，那是对方立场的基础。因此，另一方受到意识形态、自身利益、偏见或无论什么因素的影响。
Yeah. You know, I was thinking about this, the study that came out some time ago, and this was during the Obama presidency. Gas prices were really high, and people were asking, how much is the president responsible for high gas prices or low gas prices? And what was interesting is that the same group had asked the question to citizens during the presidency of George W. Bush when also gas prices were high. And what's fascinating and perhaps unsurprising is, of course, when gas prices are high and there's a Republican in the White House, most Republicans think the president has very little
是的。你知道，我一直在想这件事，这项很久以前发表的研究，当时正值奥巴马总统任期。油价非常高，人们在问，总统对高油价或低油价负有多大责任？有趣的是，在小布什总统任期内，当油价也很高时，同一个小组曾向市民提出过这个问题。令人着迷或许也不足为奇的是，当然，当油价高涨而白宫里是一位共和党总统时，大多数共和党人认为总统对油价的控制力非常小，
control over gas prices and therefore should not be blamed for it. And Democrats think the president has a lot of control of a gas price and should be blamed for it. And the tables are exactly turn when you have a Democrat in the White House. In both cases, people in very self-interested way see the data that they have and interpret it in a way that aligns with their political beliefs. Of course, this is just one example. There must be hundreds of examples like this. That's right.
因此不应该为此受到指责。而民主党人则认为总统对油价有很大的控制力，应该受到指责。当白宫里有一位民主党总统时，情况正好相反。在这两种情况下，人们都以一种极度自私的方式看待他们拥有的数据，并以符合其政治信念的方式对其进行解释。当然，这只是一个例子。这样的例子一定有成百上千个。没错。
What's amazing is it's motivated reasoning. Both of those words are important, right? So it's motivated. I'm seeing things in a way that's consistent, right, with my motives, my prior beliefs. But it's also reasoning, because they're not just saying, well, I'm just going to believe whatever makes my side look better. Done, right?
神奇的是，这是动机性推理。这两个词都很重要，对吧？所以它是出于动机的。我看到事物的方式是一致的，对吧，符合我的动机、我先前的信念。但它也是一种推理，因为他们不仅仅是在说：“好吧，反正我相信任何能让我的同伙看起来更好的东西。就这样，对吧？”
That would be just like pure motivation. There's reasoning going on. So people are actually stopping to think, okay, well, what are the factors that influence gas prices and who might be responsible for? And what's going on on the global political stage, you know, and and and so if you reason it out, these things are so complex that you can find reasons for almost anything. Mm hmm. Or at least for one of the two sides of the issue, anyway. There is another curious dimension of the bias blind spot
那将纯粹是动机驱动。其中存在着推理。所以人们实际上停下来思考，好吧，那么影响油价的因素是什么，谁可能对此负责？全球政治舞台上正在发生什么，你知道，所以如果你进行推理，这些事情太复杂了，你可以为几乎任何事情找到理由。嗯哼。或者至少为该问题的两个方面之一找到理由。偏见盲点还有一个奇特的维度，
when we come up with positions on various issues where keenly aware of the nuances and subtleties of our opinions, but we don't extend the same respect to the views of our opponents. We very rarely say the views of the people who disagree with me are thoughtful and nuanced, right? I think that's right. I think that there's more of a tendency to stereotype and caricature
当我们对各种问题形成立场时，我们敏锐地意识到我们意见中的细微差别和微妙之处，但我们并没有对对手的观点给予同样的尊重。我们极少说，那些不同意我的人的观点是深思熟虑且细致入微的，对吧？我想是的。我认为人们更有倾向去刻板印象化和漫画化
as others and to recognize the nuance and complexity in our own views. And unfortunately, the political realm, I think, affords that makes that even more likely because people can't really express their own ambivalences and nuances, right? Because that's seen as sort of giving into the other side. So people do tend to portray themselves as sort of more clear and perhaps even more extreme in that respect as a result. We've known for a long time that our evaluations of ourselves are very different than our evaluations of others.
他人，并承认我们自己观点中的细微差别和复杂性。不幸的是，我认为政治领域使得这种倾向更有可能发生，因为人们无法真正表达自己的矛盾心理和细微差别，对吧？因为这被视为对另一方的妥协。因此，人们作为结果，往往会把自己描绘得更清晰，甚至在这方面更极端。我们很早就知道，我们对自己的评价与对他人的评价截然不同。
The Bible asks why we notice a speck of dust in our brother's eye, but ignore the beam sticking out of our own eye. When we come back, the psychological quirk that produces the radically different judgments we make of ourselves and others. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. All of us find it remarkably easy to identify bias among other people, especially our opponents. And all of us find it maddeningly difficult to spot biases in ourselves.
《圣经》问为什么我们能看到弟兄眼中的刺，却看不见自己眼中的梁木。稍后回来，我们将探讨导致我们对自我和他人做出截然不同判断的心理怪癖。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们所有人都发现，在他人特别是我们的对手身上找出偏见是极其容易的。而我们所有人都发现，要在自己身上找出偏见是令人抓狂地困难。
Psychologist Emily Pronen has spent years studying this discrepancy in our perceptions, and she has found that much of the discrepancy comes down to the different yardsticks we use in judging ourselves and others. Emily, I'm not sure if you have watched the television show Vipe, but on the show, there's a character named Jonah Ryan
心理学家艾米莉·普罗宁花多年时间研究了我们认知中的这种差异，她发现这种差异很大程度上归结于我们在判断自己和他人时使用的不同标准。艾米莉，我不知道你有没有看过电视剧《副总统》，但在剧中有一个名叫乔纳·瑞安的角色，
who decides to run for president. He's been advised that it's a bad look to be single, so he gets together with a woman who happens to be the daughter of a man his mom used to be married to. So she is his step sister. In an interview, Jonah prefers to think of his fiance as only his former step sister. So what would you say to someone who might ask how can they marry their step siblings? I'm not her brother nor have I ever been her brother. Right. And the only time anyone could ever say that would be for that one year. I mean,
他决定竞选总统。有人建议他单身形象不好，于是他和一个女人在一起，而这个女人碰巧是他妈妈以前结过婚的男人的女儿。所以她是他的继妹。在一次采访中，乔纳更愿意认为他的未婚妻只是他前继妹。那么，对于可能会问“怎么能和自己的继兄弟姐妹结婚”的人，你会对他说什么？我不是她的兄弟，也从来不是她的兄弟。对。唯一能这么说的时候也只有那一年。我的意思是，
it's exactly what Woody Allen did and nobody thinks he's weird. I mean, everybody just hates him because Ann swans in as good as a bug slideugs Life. Exactly. So this is obviously a comedy show, Emily. But I'm wondering if you can just start by explaining when it comes to our judgments of other people, what is the yardstick that we use to evaluate that they are biased? The yardstick that we use is, in one word, behavior, their actions. The process is, it's almost like like if you imagine a fork in the road and it just goes two different ways there are just two different paths here. There's the path that we use for self-judgment and there's the path that we use
这完全是伍迪·艾伦做过的事，没人觉得他怪。我的意思是，每个人都讨厌他，因为……完全正确。所以这显然是一部喜剧，艾米莉。但我想知道，当谈到我们对其他人的判断时，你能不能先解释一下，我们用来评估他们有偏见标准是什么？我们使用的标准，用一个词概括，就是行为，他们的行动。这个过程是，这就好像，如果你想象道路上的一个分叉口，它只是通往两个不同的方向，这里只有两条不同的路径。一条是我们用于自我判断的路径，还有一条是我们用于
for judging others. And in my view the path that we use for judging others is we look at their actions. The path that we use for judging ourselves is we look inwards. And when I say look inwards, I mean, we look to things like our thoughts, feelings, intentions, motives. So if the question is, did I marry my brother? There's an action, there's a behavior, right? I did it or I didn't, and that's how other people will judge it.
判断他人的路径。在我看来，我们用来判断他人的路径是观察他们的行动。我们用来判断自己的路径是向内看。当我说的“向内看”时，我的意思是，我们审视诸如我们的思想、感受、意图、动机之类的事情。所以如果问题是：我嫁给了我的兄弟吗？这里有一个行动，有一种行为，对吧？我做了或者没做，其他人就是这样判断的。
But in judging myself, I might look much more to my motives and my intentions. Am I someone who would intend to marry their brother? No, that's weird. I would never intend to do that. So I guess I didn't do it. And so, when we are interacting with other people, what we see is them. We see their actions. We see their expressions. But when we experience ourselves, we don't really see that.
但在评价自己时，我可能会更多地审视我的动机和意图。我是那种会打算嫁给自己的兄弟的人吗？不，那太诡异了。我绝不会打算这么做。所以我想我没做过。因此，当我们与他人互动时，我们看到的是他们。我们看到他们的行动。我们看到他们的表情。但是当我们体验自己时，我们并没有真正看到这些。
Instead, what we perceive is what's inside our heads. That's the information that we're flooded with. That's the information that we can't escape is our thoughts and feelings and intentions. So that's what we give so much weight to. So one of the things that jumps out at me from what you're saying, Emily, is that our introspection is our access to our own thoughts and feelings. These are with us all the time.
相反，我们感知到的是我们脑海里的东西。那是充斥着我们的信息。那是我们无法逃避的信息，也就是我们的思想、感受和意图。所以这就是我们赋予如此大权重的对象。因此，从你所说的话中跳出来的其中一件事，艾米莉，就是我们的内省是我们通往自己思想和感受的途径。这些东西一直伴随着我们。
So it's almost, we don't actually have to ask ourselves the question, how do I evaluate myself? We automatically go to looking inward to our thoughts and feelings. When it comes to our evaluations of other people, in some ways we don't have access to their thoughts and feelings. Those are hidden from us, and so we use what we have. And on the surface, this happens without any sort of conscious awareness that it's happening, right? So I don't realize I'm using a different yardstick to evaluate your behavior and a different yardstick to evaluate my.
所以几乎可以说，我们实际上不必问自己这个问题：“我如何评价自己？”我们自动就会向内寻找我们的思想和感受。当涉及到我们对其他人的评估时，在某些方面我们无法接触到他们的思想和感受。这些对我们来说是隐藏的，所以我们只能利用我们所拥有的东西。表面上看，这一切发生时没有任何意识层面的觉察，对吧？所以我没有意识到我在用一个标准来评估你的行为，而用另一个标准来评估我的行为。
Right. I don't think that we really think about that explicitly. What we use in any judgment, psychologists can tell you, is the information that's salient. Psychologists like that term salient. The information that's available to us, whatever's fresh in our brains is the information we use. And so it just so happens that for the self, the information that's fresh in our brains,
没错。我认为我们并没有明确地思考过这个问题。心理学家可以告诉你，我们在任何判断中使用的都是显眼的信息。心理学家喜欢“显眼”这个词。我们可以获得的信息，无论大脑中最新鲜的是什么，都是我们使用的信息。因此，碰巧对于自我而言，大脑中最新鲜的信息，
all the time is that stuff that we perceive to be in our brains, right? Our thoughts and feelings, all that stuff that we perceive to be in our brains, right? Our thoughts and feelings, all that stuff that's sort of just constantly there and that we're sort of constantly aware of. It's not just that we use different yardsticks in evaluating ourselves and others. Each of those yardsticks is flawed and flawed in a different way. When it comes to evaluating our own behavior through introspection, we imagine that we can see all our motives and intentions that they are accessible to us. But it turns out that is not the case.
一直都是我们感知到在大脑中的那些东西，对吧？我们的思想和感受，所有那些我们感知到在大脑中的东西，对吧？我们的思想和感受，所有那些仿佛一直在那里，而我们又仿佛一直在觉察的东西。不仅仅是我们评估自己和他人时使用了不同的标准。每一个标准本身都有瑕疵，而且瑕疵各不相同。当通过内省来评估我们自己的行为时，我们想象自己能看到所有的动机和意图，它们对我们是触手可及的。但事实并非如此。
There's a bunch of stuff that goes on in our brand that we're not aware of, right? We're not aware of the sources of our beliefs. We're not aware of, you know, if I go to the ice cream shop and I choose the chocolate ice cream over the vanilla, I am aware that that was my choice, but I'm not aware why that was my choice. That's happening in the brain without my having access to it, but we sometimes forget that. So we think that we can look inwards and find out everything. So we forget, for example, that a lot of prejudice and stereotyping happens unconsciously. And I mean, I can't look inwards to find it. I'm not necessarily going to have those racist intentions.
我们的大脑里发生了很多我们并不知情的事情，对吧？我们并不清楚自己信念的来源，比方说，如果我去冰淇淋店，在香草味和巧克力味之间选择了巧克力味，我知道那是我的选择，但我并不知道为什么那是我的选择。那是在大脑中发生的，而我却无法接触到它，但我们有时会忘记这一点。所以我们认为我们可以向内看并发现一切。因此我们忘记了，例如，很多偏见和刻板印象都是在无意识中发生的。我的意思是，我无法通过向内看找到它。我未必会有那些种族主义的意图。
That's something that people talk about a lot now. So it's not the case that just because we have access to all this information in our heads, that that means it's always going to be probative for making whatever judgment we need to make. I remember speaking some years ago with the researcher Michael Tesla, he ran an interesting experiment with Republicans and Democrats and this is back when the country was debating the Affordable Care Act or Obama Care. And what Michael Tesla did is he presented volunteers with details of the Affordable Care Act, but he told some of them that the plan had been put forward by President Bill Clinton, a Democratic President who was white, and he told other volunteers the plan was from Barack Obama, a Democratic president who was black.
这是现在人们经常谈论的话题。因此，并不是说仅仅因为我们能获取脑海中的所有这些信息，就意味着它对做出我们需要做出的任何判断总是具有证明力的。我记得多年前与研究员迈克尔·特斯勒交谈过，他和共和党人以及民主党人做了一个有趣的实验，当时国家正在争论《平价医疗法案》即奥巴马医改。迈克尔·特斯勒做的是，他向志愿者展示了《平价医疗法案》的细节，但他告诉其中一些人，该计划是由白人民主党总统比尔·克林顿提出的，而他告诉其他志愿者，该计划来自黑人民主党总统贝拉克·奥巴马。
So same plan, same details, both put forward by a Democratic president, except that one was white and one president was black. And what he found was that both liberals and conservatives were subtly biased by their feelings about the racial identity of the president. White racial liberals become more supportive of a policy when it's framed as Barack Obama than when it's framed as Bill Clinton's, but white racial conservatives become less supportive of that policy. And Emily, I feel like this is speaking to what you just said. If you ask liberals and conservatives, how are you evaluating this policy? They will
所以是相同的计划，相同的细节，都是由民主党总统提出的，只不过一个是白人总统，一个是黑人总统。他发现，自由派和保守派都微妙地受到了他们对总统种族身份的情感偏见的影响。当白人种族自由主义者被告知该政策是由贝拉克·奥巴马制定时，他们会更加支持该政策，而当被告知是由比尔·克林顿制定时，支持度则会下降；但白人种族保守主义者对该政策的支持度却会降低。艾米莉，我觉得这正印证了你刚才所说的话。如果你问自由派和保守派，你们是如何评估这项政策的？他们会
dive into the details and say, here's why I like the policy or here's why I don't like the policy. And neither will say my affinity or my aversion to someone from a different race might be shaping my view on something like the Affordable Care Act. Yeah, I think that's exactly right. And that sounds like a great study. And it's not that the subjects were lying. They were saying what they believed to be the case. They assumed, incorrectly, that if the race of the candidate had impacted their judgment that they would know it.
深入探讨细节并说：“这就是我喜欢这项政策的原因，或者这就是我不喜欢这项政策的原因。”没有人会说，我对某个不同种族的人的好感或反感，可能会塑造我对诸如《平价医疗法案》之类事情的看法。是的，我认为完全正确。这听起来像是一个很棒的研究。这并不是说受试者在撒谎。他们说的是他们认为是事实的话。他们错误地假设，如果候选人的种族影响了他们的判断，他们是会知道的。
Now an outsider might be able to notice this pattern much more quickly because they wouldn't be relying on their their intentions. They just be looking at what the person did. Right? So sometimes when we look at behavior, things can be a little bit easier to see. Yeah. Some years ago, Emily, you came up with a theory of why our introspection are undrilivable. You called it the introspection illusion. What is the introspection illusion? Although we have access to our introspection, This is sort of what it means to be a conscious person as you know your thoughts and your feelings and your motives and your intentions and they're there all the time in your head. We have some illusions about what that can do for us. So we think that that gives us sort of supreme self-knowledge, sort of that we can know all
现在，局外人可能会更快地注意到这种模式，因为他们不会依赖他们的意图。他们只会看这个人在做什么。对吧？所以有时当我们观察行为时，事情会更容易看清一些。是的。几年前，艾米莉，你提出了一个关于为什么我们的内省是不可靠的理论。你称之为内省错觉。什么是内省错觉？尽管我们可以进行内省，这有点像作为一个有意识的人的意义，你知道你的思想、你的感受、你的动机和你的意图，它们一直都在你的脑海里。对于这能为我们做些什么，我们存在一些错觉。所以我们认为这赋予了我们某种至高无上的自我认知，就好像我们可以了解
sorts of things about ourselves because we have access to this information. We also think that our behavior is less important than knowing what's inside of our heads. In the case of ourselves, it's our intentions that are so important to know. You know, I was speaking some years ago with Mazarin Banaji, the psychologist at Harvard, and she said something really interesting to me.
关于我们自己的各种事情，因为我们可以获取这些信息。我们还认为我们的行为不如了解我们脑海中的东西那么重要。就我们自己而言，了解我们的意图是如此重要。你知道，几年前我曾与哈佛大学的心理学家马扎林·班纳吉交谈过，她对我说了一件非常有趣的事。
She said, you know, if you have a problem with your heart, you might go to a cardiologist to get it checked out. And the cardiologist says, here's what's wrong with your heart. You are inclined to believe her because you think the cardiologist knows more than you do about your heart. You don't tell the cardiologist it's my heart. Therefore, I must be the expert on my heart because it belongs to me.
她说：“你知道，如果你的心脏有问题，你可能会去找心脏病专家检查一下。心脏病专家说：‘你的心脏这里有问题。’你倾向于相信她，因为你认为心脏病专家比你更了解你的心脏。你不会对心脏病专家说：‘这是我的心脏，因此我必定是自己心脏的专家，因为它属于我。’”
But my serenity was saying the same thing doesn't happen with our minds. It's very hard when an expert comes along and says, let me explain to you how your mind works because at some level, all of us feel like we are experts in our own minds. And that's partly I think connected to what you're calling the introspection illusion.
但马扎林想说的是，我们的思维并没有发生同样的情况。当一个专家出现并说“让我向你解释你的思维是如何运作的”时，这是非常困难的，因为在某种程度上，我们所有人都觉得自己是自己思维的专家。我认为这部分与你所说的“内省错觉”有关。
It feels like our mental worlds are so rich and we spend so much time in them that it feels in some ways we understand how they work. And in some ways, that could be an illusion. That's right. And look, it's embedded in the history of our own field. In the very early days of psychology, when people wanted to understand the mind,
感觉我们的精神世界是如此丰富，我们在其中花费了如此多的时间，以至于在某种程度上我们觉得我们了解它们是如何运作的。在某些方面，这可能是一种错觉。没错。而且看，它嵌入在我们自己领域的历史中。在心理学的早期，当人们想要理解思维时，
they had people come into the laboratory, sit in a room, and interest back. And they said, this is how we're going to learn understand the mind. They had people come into the laboratory, sit in a room, and interest back. And they said, this is how we're going to learn how the mind works. And then there was a huge backlash. The behaviorists came along and they said, this is nonsense. We cannot learn about how the mind works by asking people to
他们让人们进入实验室，坐在房间里进行内省。他们说：“这就是我们将要学习理解思维的方式。”他们让人们进入实验室，坐在房间里进行内省。他们说：“这就是我们将要学习思维工作原理的方式。”然后出现了巨大的强烈反弹。行为主义者随之出现，他们说：“这简直是无稽之谈。我们不能通过要求人们向我们汇报思维中发生的事情来了解思维的工作原理。”
report to us what's going on in their mind. So they said, we're getting rid of all of that. So we're just going to focus on behavior because that is observable. And then we had a third wave of cognitive psychology where we realized that there were objective strategies and parable methods that we could use to study the mind that did not rely on people telling us what was going on in their own minds. And I think part of this also rests on the idea that if everything that happens in our
所以他们说：“我们要摆脱所有这一切。我们只关注行为，因为那是可观察的。”然后我们迎来了认知心理学的第三次浪潮，我们意识到我们可以使用客观的策略和可对标的方法来研究思维，而不依赖于人们告诉我们他们自己的思维中正在发生什么。我想这部分也基于这样一种想法：如果发生在我们的
mind was actually accessible to conscious introspection, we might in fact, if we were very honest and very diligent, be able to look inside our minds and see everything, but in fact, if much of our minds actually are offering outside of our conscious awareness, what our minds are doing is simply not accessible to us through introspection. Right, exactly. You brought up the halo effect when we were talking earlier. And the famous experiment on the halo effect comes from Tim Wilson and Richard Nusbit back in 1977.
思维中的一切实际上都可以通过意识内省来获取，那么事实上，如果我们非常诚实和勤奋，我们或许能够审视我们的内心并看到一切，但事实上，如果我们思维的很大一部分实际上是在我们的意识觉察之外运作的，那么我们的思维在做什么，通过内省是根本无法获取的。没错，完全正确。我们刚才谈话时你提到了光环效应。关于光环效应的著名实验来自蒂姆·威尔逊和理查德·尼斯贝特，时间是在1977年。
And they had people watch a video in which a professor with a quote unquote foreign accent, I'm not sure what his accent was talking. And then they asked subjects in the experiment to evaluate this professor. And half of the subjects had seen the professor in the video acting cold, not very likable. And the other half of subjects had seen him acting warm, very likable. And afterwards, they asked the subjects what they thought of him. And what people said in the unlikable professor condition was that they didn't like his accent when they were asked about his accent. In the likable condition, they did like his accent.
他们让人们观看一段视频，视频中一个带着所谓“外国口音”的教授在说话（我不确定他的口音是什么样的）。然后他们让实验中的受试者评估这位教授。一半的受试者看到视频中的教授表现冷淡，不太讨人喜欢。另一半受试者看到他表现热情，非常讨人喜欢。事后，他们问受试者对他有什么看法。在教授不讨人喜欢的组里，当被问及口音时，人们说他们不喜欢他的口音。在讨人喜欢的组里，他们确实喜欢他的口音。
So what happened was the likability of the professor, which was manipulated by the experimenters, influenced how much people thought the accent was likable. But they didn't realize that this had happened at all. They had no access to what had influenced their perception of the accent. Now, we knew as experimenters, right? Because we saw those who got the unlikable professor thought it was a bad accent, and those who got the likable professor thought it was a good accent. So the experimenters could say, gee, we know how they came to this conclusion. But the subject didn't know that the subject just looked inwards and said,
所以发生的情况是，由实验者操纵的教授讨人喜欢与否，影响了人们认为其口音有多讨人喜欢。但他们根本没有意识到这一点。他们无法接触到是什么影响了他们对口音的感知。现在，作为实验者，我们是知道的，对吧？因为我们看到那些遇到不讨人喜欢教授的人认为那是糟糕的口音，而那些遇到讨人喜欢教授的人认为那是好口音。所以实验者可以说：“天哪，我们知道他们是怎么得出这个结论的。”但受试者并不知道，受试者只是向内看并说：
that's a bunch of hooy. Why would I evaluate someone's accent, how likable their accent is, based on how nice they were that makes no sense? They had no awareness of having done that. It occurred unconsciously, and they denied it. You can see the same thing play out on a much larger scale when it comes to politics. In the 2020 US presidential election,
纯粹是无稽之谈。我怎么会根据别人的善良程度去评估他们的口音以及口音有多讨人喜欢呢？这根本说不通！他们完全没有意识到自己这么做了。这是在潜意识中发生的，而且他们对此予以否认。当你把目光转向政治领域时，会发现类似的情况在更大的规模上演。在2020年美国总统大选中，
the vast majority of Republicans voted for the Republican candidate and the vast majority of Democrats voted for the Republican candidate, and the vast majority of Democrats voted for the Democratic candidate. Many people, if you ask them, why did you choose the candidate you voted for, they would give you a nuanced explanation of why candidate A was better than candidate B. But imagine that you're a neutral observer who just landed in the United States from Mars. You might look at the same results and say, well, people are just voting for their parties candidate. It doesn't really make a difference who that person is. Most people tend to dislike such comments
“这纯属无稽之谈。我怎么会根据一个人有多讨人喜欢来评估他的口音、他的口音有多讨人喜欢呢？这根本说不通。”他们完全没有意识到自己曾这样做过。这是无意识发生的，他们对此予以否认。在政治领域，当涉及到更大的规模时，你可以看到同样的事情上演。在2020年美国总统大选中，
because they suggest that our choices are less deliberate than we think. They prompt us to search for justifications that prove that we are, in fact, in charge of our own minds. That's right. We think we're being rational that we're choosing the candidate based on rational decision making and rational analysis, but really what we're doing is we're rationalizing.
因为它们表明我们的选择远没有我们想象的那样深思熟虑。它们促使我们寻找各种理由来证明我们实际上掌控着自己的思想。没错。我们以为自己很理性，以为自己是基于理性的决策和理性的分析来选择候选人的，但实际上我们在做的是寻找借口进行自我合理化。
Really actually, there's other factors that have determined which candidate we prefer. And then after the fact, we rationalize it by coming up with what seem like rational reasons. And it feels like our evaluations of ourselves and others, you know, is shaped by these dual forces. On the one hand, we ascribe greater weight to our own introspection than maybe we should. But on the other, we discount the introspection of other people.
事实上，真正决定我们偏好哪个候选人的其实是其他因素。事后，我们会通过寻找看似合理的理由来进行合理化解释。我们对自我和他人（你知道的）的评估似乎是由这两种力量塑造的。一方面，我们赋予了自身内省比可能应有的更高的分量；但另一方面，我们却忽视了其他人的内省。
So in other words, I don't think that my political opponents have actually thought very carefully about how they've chosen their course of action. I sort of can dismiss them as being easily led as being sheep. Even as we overvalue our own introspection, we undervalue the internal thought processes of other people. Yes. And we've even done experiments where we say, look,
换句话说，我不认为我的政治对手在选择他们行动方案时真的进行了非常仔细的思考。我可以把他们轻描淡写地视为容易被牵着鼻子走、像羊群一样盲从的人。尽管我们过高估计了自己的内省，但我们却低估了其他人内部的思维过程。是的。我们甚至做过这样的实验，我们说，看，
maybe the reason why people undervalued other's thought processes is that they just don't have access to them, right? You know, you have such rich access to what's going on in your head. So we will give people an entire think aloud protocol, meaning that before the subject made their decision, they thought allowed into a tape recorder. They just dumped all their thoughts and will give that to the subject to hear. And they still disregard it. So we actually did a study with political beliefs. And this was with Jonah Berger and Sarah Maluki, we made up various California propositions. One was about increasing the maximum cargo size at the port of Los Angeles. When then we told people, there are parties positioned on them.
人们低估他人思维过程的原因，可能只是他们无法接触到这些过程，对吧？你知道的，你对自己脑子里发生的事情有着如此丰富的触达。所以我们会给人们提供一套完整的大声思考协议，这意味着在受试者做出决定之前，他们把自己的想法大声说进录音机里。他们把所有的想法都倾倒出来，然后把这些给受试者听。但他们仍然不理睬这些。所以我们实际上做了一项关于政治信仰的研究。这是与乔纳·伯格（Jonah Berger）和萨拉·马卢基（Sarah Maluki）合作完成的，我们虚构了各种加利福尼亚州的提案。其中一个是关于增加洛杉矶港最大集装箱货物尺寸的。然后我们告诉人们，各方对此有不同的立场。
So the Democrats support this or there are Republicans support this. And we ask them to choose their position to vote essentially. And we ask them were they influenced by their parties position? And Subject said, no, I wasn't influenced by that. I just evaluated the issue. Before they said what position they would take, we had them list all their thoughts. They dumped out all of their thoughts on the issue.
民主党人支持这个，或者共和党人支持这个。然后我们让他们选择自己的立场，本质上就是进行投票。我们问他们是否受到了他们政党立场的影响？受试者说，没有，我没有受那个影响。我只是评估了这个议题。在他们说出自己将采取什么立场之前，我们让他们列出了所有的想法。他们倾倒了自己对这个议题的所有想法。
And then we gave that to another person to also evaluate, and the other person didn't care about any of that. So people said, I went with my thoughts, I evaluated the issue, but the outsider said, oh gee, I don't need to see all those thoughts, that's not relevant. You're a Democrat, you want the Democratic, oh gee, I don't need to see all those thoughts. That's not relevant. You're a Democrat.
然后我们把这些交给另一个人去评估，而另一个人根本不在乎这些。所以人们说，我是根据自己的想法做决定的，我评估了这个问题，但局外人却说，哦天哪，我不需要看那些想法，那不重要。你是民主党人，你想要民主党的立场。哦天哪，我不需要看那些想法。那不重要。你是民主党人。
You want the Democratic position. Done. Simple. One of the other ideas that's connected to your work on how we overvalue the things happening in our minds and pay less attention to the things happening in other people's minds is a phenomenon called naive realism. Can you talk about what that is and how it connects to your work? So much of what we're talking about today, I think, is really rooted in the basic functioning
你想要民主党的立场。搞定。很简单。另一个与你的研究相关的观点是，我们如何过高估计自己脑海中发生的事情，而较少关注其他人脑海中发生的事情，这种现象被称为朴素实在论。你能谈谈那是什么以及它与你的工作有什么联系吗？我认为我们今天讨论的很多内容，实际上都植根于我们大脑的基本运作方式
of our brains. It's just how we are designed, right? So for example, we have eyes in our head, and those lead us to see other people's behaviors, but the eyes don't look inwards. And there's just sort of basic brain architecture that determines so much. And now you've realized some has to do with this. It has to do with the idea that there are some basic brain architecture that determines so much. And I have realism has to do with this. It has to do with the idea that there are some basic and inescapable beliefs. And one is that I believe that I see the world as it is in objective reality.
中。这正是我们的设计方式，对吧？所以例如，我们的长着眼睛，这些眼睛引导我们去看到其他人的行为，但眼睛不会向内看。正是这种基本的大脑架构决定了很多事情。现在，你意识到的某些事情与此有关。它与这样一种观点有关：有一些基本的大脑架构决定了太多的东西。而我具有现实感也与此有关。它与这样一种观点有关：存在一些基本且不可逃避的信念。其中之一就是我相信自己是以客观现实的原貌来看待世界的。
And as a result, I think that others will see the world the same as I do. And that when others don't, I have to explain it. And the way that I tend to explain it is either by saying, they don't understand, I need to educate them, or failing that saying, there's something wrong with them. Either they're stupid, or they're biased. You can see naive realism at work in everyday interactions. Take, for example, something that the comedian George Carlin observed.
因此，我认为其他人也会和我一样看到这个世界。而当其他人没有这样做时，我必须做出解释。我倾向于解释的方式要么是说，他们不明白，我需要教育他们；要么在做不到这一点时说，他们脑子有点问题。要么他们很愚蠢，要么他们有偏见。你可以在日常互动中看到朴素实在论的作用。比如，喜剧演员乔治·卡林（George Carlin）观察到的一个现象。
Have you ever noticed when you're driving that anyone who's driving slower than you is an idiot? And anyone driving faster than you is a maniac! Yes, I love that quote. It reminds me of one time I was in the kitchen preparing some food and my seven year old was in the playroom with my father, his ground father, and they were looking at different cars in a magazine, and my son kept preferring the big SUVs, you know, and my father preferred the little boxer-type cars, and at some point my father said to him, I know what's a matter of taste, but your taste is stupid. That's a great story. That's a wonderful story.
你有没有注意到，当你开车时，任何开得比你慢的人都是个白痴？而任何开得比你快的人都是个疯子！是的，我很喜欢那句话。这让我想起有一次我在厨房准备食物，我七岁的孩子和我的父亲（也就是他的爷爷）在游戏室里，他们在看一本杂志上的不同汽车，我儿子一直更喜欢大型SUV，你知道的，而我父亲更喜欢小型平卧发动机式的汽车，有一刻我父亲对他说：“我知道这是个品味问题，但你的品味太蠢了。”这真是一个好故事。这是一个绝妙的故事。
I feel it speaks to something that I think is really important. Parents and teachers are constantly trying to teach this lesson. Don't jump to conclusions, slow down, don't assume you know what's happening in someone else's head. And yet it's so hard to remember to practice these lessons, right? I mean, as a parent and as a teacher yourself, do you sometimes go, I'm doing the exact same thing.
我觉得这说得很深刻，我觉得这真的非常重要。父母和老师一直在试图教导这个道理：不要下结论，慢下来，不要自以为知道别人心里在想什么。然而，要记住去实践这些道理是多么难，对吧？我的意思是，作为父母和老师，你有时会不会觉得，我正在做着同样的事情——
I tell my kids not to do. Yes, because these things are so automatic and so natural. These are tendencies that we have to override in ourselves. We can't eliminate them, right? Because so the tendency to think you see the world as it is, an objective reality. And therefore, if you like the race car better than the SUV that it truly is better, that tendency is sort of an escapeable. And when children do it, they don't realize even that there's a distinction when they're
我告诉我的孩子不要去做的事。是的，因为这些事情太自动了、太自然了。这些是我们必须在自己身上去克制、超越的倾向。我们无法消除它们，对吧？因为那种认为自己看到的世界就是它本来的样子、是一种客观现实的倾向。因此，如果你觉得赛车比SUV更好，它就真的更好，这种倾向某种程度上是无法摆脱的。当小孩子们这样做时，他们甚至没有意识到，在他们
young between their perception as reality. As we get older, we come to recognize, right, oh, wait a second, that's a distinction when they're young between their perception is reality. As we get older, we come to recognize, wait a second, that's a matter of taste. At some level we come to realize, oh no, there's different perspectives and it's a martyr. But that initial belief that we have from childhood that my perception is reality doesn't really go away. And so it does actually feel that the car we prefers the better one. There are lots of implications that stem from what Emily calls this basic
年幼的时候，他们的感知和现实之间是有区别的。随着年龄的增长，我们开始认识到，对吧，哦，等一下，那是……在他们年幼的时候，他们的感知与现实之间是有区别的。随着年龄的增长，我们开始认识到，等一下，那只是个口味问题。在某种程度上，我们开始意识到，哦不，有不同的视角，这是一个……但我们从小就有的那种“我的感知就是现实”的最初信念并没有真正消失。所以，我们确实会觉得我们偏爱的那辆车就是更好的那辆。有很多启示都源于艾米莉所说的这种大脑的基本
architecture of the brain. Here is one that should be familiar to all of us. If I'm late for a meeting, my mind is chock full with all the reasons I'm late. Traffic was terrible, I had a childcare crisis and so on. But if someone else is late for a meeting, I don't have access to all that stuff happening inside their heads. It's easy for me to think of them as just being irresponsible or careless. Psychologists call this the fundamental attribution error. Another implication of this work has to do with the phenomenon of magical thinking.
架构。这里有一个我们都应该很熟悉的例子。如果我开会迟到了，我的脑子里塞满了各种我迟到的理由：交通糟糕透顶、我遇到了育儿危机等等。但如果是别人开会迟到了，我无法接触到他们脑子里发生的那些事情。我很轻易就会认为他们只是不负责任或粗心大意。心理学家称之为基本归因错误。这项研究的另一个启示与神奇思维（magical thinking）的现象有关。
Magical thinking involves the idea that our thoughts could somehow influence the world around us. So, for example, if I think ill thoughts about you, can that give you a headache? Or if I think positive thoughts about my favorite player on the team, will that help them score a goal? And we found that, in fact, this was the case. So for example, we had people think evil thoughts about someone else in the experiment. We said we're interested in whether you could place a hex
神奇思维包含这样一种观点：我们的思想可以以某种方式影响我们周围的世界。所以，例如，如果我对你有不好的想法，那会让你头疼吗？或者，如果我对队里最喜欢的球员产生积极的想法，那会帮他们进球吗？我们发现，事实确实如此。例如，我们在实验中让一些人对其他人产生邪恶的想法。我们说，我们想知道你是否可以对这个人下个蛊
on the person and then they stuck pins in a voodoo doll. And then the other person reported a headache because they worked for us and we told them to. And what happened was if you were told to think ill about the other person before putting those pins in, you were told, just take a minute and think of something terrible. Just think of the worst thing you can happening to this person. And then you stuck the pins in the doll. Then you felt like you caused the headache and you felt bad. And we found the same thing with basketball. Before a big university basketball game,
，然后他们在巫毒娃娃上扎针。接着，另一个人报告说头疼了，因为他们为我们工作，我们就是这么指示他们的。结果是，如果你在把针扎进去之前被告知要想对方的坏话，你被告知：花上一分钟，想点糟糕的事情。只要想你能想到的发生在这个人身上最糟糕的事。然后你把针扎进娃娃里。那时你会觉得是你导致了头疼，你感觉很糟糕。我们在篮球运动中也发现了同样的情况。在大学的一场重要篮球比赛之前，
we had people think about the different players and think about how each one of them could contribute to the game and how would they help their team score well. And then we asked them after the game how much impact they felt that their thoughts had on the score of the game. So they thought that they'd impacted the game when they had thought about the players doing well. And the way that it's related is it again involves putting too much weight
我们让人们思考不同的球员，思考他们每个人能为比赛做些什么贡献，以及他们将如何帮助他们的球队取得好成绩。然后我们在赛后询问他们，觉得自己的想法对比赛的比分有多大影响。所以当他们想到球员表现很好时，他们就觉得自己的想法影响了比赛。这种联系的方式在于，它再次涉及对我们脑子里发生的事情赋予了过多的权重
on what's going on inside our heads. Because we're basically saying that what's going on inside my head could give someone else a headache or what's going on inside my head when I sit in the stands of a basketball game could influence the players' score. How many baskets they shot. I mean, if it's a critical moment in the game, I would feel terrible getting up to leave the room and get some popcorn. I feel like, I can't let my team down.
。因为我们基本上是在说，我脑子里发生的事情可以给别人带来头疼，或者当我坐在篮球比赛的看台上时，我脑子里发生的事情可以影响球员的比分——他们投进了多少个球。我的意思是，如果那是比赛的关键时刻，我要是起身离开房间去买点爆米花，我会觉得糟透了。我觉得，我不能让我的球队失望。
How could I do that to them? The introspection illusion, the biased blind spot and naive realism have profound consequences in our daily lives. They do more than shape our thinking in basketball games. They shape life and death decisions and choices to go to war. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Psychologist Emily Pronen has found we judge ourselves very differently from the way we judge
我怎么能对他们做出这种事？内省错觉、偏见盲点和朴素实在论在我们的日常生活中会产生深远的影响。它们不仅仅塑造了我们在篮球比赛中的思维。它们塑造了生死抉择和发动战争的选择。我们稍后回来。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。心理学家艾米莉·普罗宁发现，我们评价自己的方式与评价他人的方式截然不同。
others. This is because we use different yardstakes while doing those two things. We evaluate others based on their behavior, but we evaluate our own actions using introspection, and it turns out introspection is not a useful guide to understanding our own minds. Emily, I want to talk about some of the implications of this work and the ways in which it plays out in the real world, and I want to start with an example of something that can seem trivial, but that produces widespread conflict across the United States. I'm going to let Wuppie Goldberg explain.
这是因为我们在做这两件事时使用了不同的标尺。我们根据别人的行为来评价他们，但我们用内省来评价自己的行动，结果证明，内省并不是理解我们自己心灵的有用指南。艾米莉，我想谈谈这项工作的一些启示，以及它在现实世界中的表现方式，我想从一件看似微不足道、却在美国各地引发广泛冲突的事情的一个例子开始。我让乌比·戈德堡来解释一下。
A survey found that one of the most common arguments this time of year in households across America is what temperature to put thermostat at? Right. Everybody relates. Oh my gosh. I mean, you are like, uh-huh? Yeah. Everybody, everybody, we race. We are like, uh-huh. Yeah. There's a lot of stuff we should be talking about,
一项调查发现，一年中的这个时候，美国家庭中最常见的争论之一是：把恒温器调到什么温度？对吧。每个人都深有同感。天哪。我的意思是，你会想：呃-哈？是的。每个人，每个人，我们都深有同感。我们想：呃-哈？是的。有很多事情我们本该讨论，
because it's on the list, but this interest made. Because I feel like everybody deals with this, if you're interested. So Emily, I want to draw attention to the fact that this is a topic which you bring up. Almost everyone has an opinion about it and the opinion is often heated. Tell me how it connects to the conversation we're having about how we think about our minds, other people's minds, and the judgments we arrive at.
因为它们在清单上，但这个太吸引人了。因为我觉得如果大家对此感兴趣的话，每个人都会遇到这个问题。所以艾米莉，我想提请大家注意这样一个事实：这是你提出的一个话题。几乎每个人都有看法，而且这种看法往往很激烈。请告诉我，这与我们正在进行的关于“我们如何看待自己的大脑、别人的大脑以及我们得出的判断”的对话有何联系。
I just love the idea of the thermostat wars is it's just it's so real. And I think it goes back to that quote. I know it's a matter of taste, but your taste is stupid. Because essentially, if I think that the temperature should be set to 73 and you think it should be set to 68, I do realize that this is a matter of taste, right? That there's no right answer here. But at another level, I actually think that the temperature that I wanted to be at is the correct one. And it's like that George Carlin quote, right? If you want it to be hotter than me, you're a little soft and ridiculous, you know, and you're wasting a lot of energy.
我太喜欢恒温器之争这个概念了，因为它太真实了。我想这可以追溯到那句名言：我知道这只是个口味问题，但你的口味太蠢了。因为本质上，如果我认为温度应该设为73度，而你认为应该设为68度，我确实意识到这是一个口味问题，对吧？这里没有正确答案。但在另一个层面上，我其实认为我想要的那个温度才是正确的。这就有点像乔治·卡林的那句名言，对吧？如果你想比我更热，那你有点娇弱和可笑，你知道的，你还在浪费大量的能量。
If you want it to be colder than me, you've got to be kidding. Do you really need to be that aesthetic and suffer like that? We can turn up the heat a little bit more, right? So we think it's a matter of taste, but we also think we're right. And I've done some research with Nate Sheik and Shane Blackman where we show this with paintings. People say, oh, paintings, that's a matter of taste. Until someone disagrees with them about which are the nice paintings
如果你想比我更冷，你在开玩笑吧。你真的需要那么清心寡欲并遭受这种罪吗？我们可以把暖气再调高一点，对吧？所以我们认为这是一个口味问题，但我们也认为自己是对的。我和内特·希克（Nate Sheik）以及谢恩·布莱克曼（Shane Blackman）做过一些研究，我们通过画作展示了这一点。人们会说，哦，画作，那是口味问题。直到有人在“哪些是好画、哪些是烂画”这个问题上与他们意见不合。
and which are the bad paintings. And then all of a sudden, they say that that person is wrong. Tell me a little bit more about the art study. I'm fascinated by the examples that you used and what you found. So Shane collected some images of paintings from art history books. So these were paintings by famous artists. And they were in major museums. And they were arranged from abstract to portraits, and we would show them to a subject and ask them to rate which ones they thought were truly great and which ones they thought were overrated. And then we showed them cover story for this of another subject who had supposedly done
然后突然之间，他们就会说那个人错了。跟我多讲讲这个艺术研究吧。我对你使用的例子以及你的发现着迷。所以谢恩从艺术史书中收集了一些画作的图像。这些都是著名艺术家的画作。它们陈列在各大博物馆里。它们从抽象派到肖像画都有，我们会把它们展示给受试者，让他们评判哪些是他们认为真正伟大的，哪些是他们认为被高估的。然后我们向他们提供了一个关于另一个受试者的虚构背景故事，据说那个人也做了
the same task, but that subject totally disagreed with them. So if I thought it was great, they thought it was overrated and vice versa. And then they had to evaluate this other person. And although they said that opinions on art were a matter of taste, when they saw this person who disagreed with them, they actually thought that the person was wrong and had been influenced by improper influences, because otherwise they surely would have agreed with oneself. And we've done studies with chefs, Kobe Sassarski, my student, did a study with chefs and chefs showed this exact phenomenon, right?
同样的任务，但那个人的看法与他们完全相左。因此，如果我觉得它很棒，他们就会觉得它被高估了，反之亦然。然后受试者必须评估这个人。尽管他们说过对艺术的看法是个口味问题，但当他们看到这个与自己意见不合的人时，他们实际上认为这个人错了，并且受到了不正当影响，因为否则的话，对方肯定会同意他们自己的看法。我们还和厨师们做过研究，我的学生科比·萨萨尔斯基（Kobe Sassarski）和厨师们做了一项研究，厨师们也表现出了这种确切的现象，对吧？
There's an objectively correct amount that the meat should be cooked, that the pasta should be cooked, you know how much it should be salted, and those who do it the other way are wrong. I want to point to something that you said earlier that I think might connect with this, which is in some ways, when we think about our own subjective conclusions, when we think about a painting or how long past I should be cooked, we're actually not thinking of this as being subjective. It genuinely feels as if we have a master, a whole bunch of objective
肉应该煮到客观上正确的程度，意大利面应该煮到客观上正确的程度，你知道应该放多少盐，而那些用其他方式烹饪的人就是错的。我想指出你刚才说过的一句话，我觉得这可能与此有关，也就是说，在某种程度上，当我们思考自己主观的结论时，当我们思考一幅画或意大利面应该煮多久时，我们其实并不认为这是主观的。它真切地让人感觉我们掌握了大师级的、全套的客观
data, and a right to this conclusion that in some ways feels objective. So, you know, we might say, yes, my taste in art and music is subjective, but it actually feels like it's not that it's actually objective. And part of it is that when things come to us through the senses, it comes so quickly that we do not feel the operation of the mind being involved. I know if I preferred to get the chocolate ice cream to the mint chip ice cream, but if you ask me why, I simply don't have access to that. And so it doesn't feel like there's been all these intervening processes that could have biased it. So when the piece of food hits my mouth and I think that it has too much salt, I don't have access to any brain processes
数据，并且有权得出这个在某种程度上感觉很客观的结论。所以，你知道，我们可以说，是的，我在艺术和音乐方面的品味是主观的，但它实际上感觉并不主观，而是实实在在的客观。部分原因在于，当事物通过感官传达到我们这里时，速度太快了，以至于我们感觉不到大脑运作的参与。我知道我是否更喜欢巧克力冰激凌而不是薄荷巧克力冰激凌，但如果你问我为什么，我根本无法探知其中的原因。因此，感觉并不存在任何可能使其产生偏见的介入过程。所以，当食物进入我的口中，而我认为它太咸时，我无法触及任何正在影响这种判断的大脑过程。
that are influencing that judgment. It's just, yeah, that's too salty. And it's an immediate feeling and because it is so immediate, it's hard to imagine that it could have been biased by anything. I'm wondering if this is connected in some way, Emily, to other work that you have done that looks at how we perform during interviews, but also how we judge other people during interviews. So we all think that we can sit before someone for half an hour, talk to them, and get a pretty good sense of whether this person
这只是：嗯，这太咸了。这是一种即时的感觉，正因为它是如此即时，所以很难想象它会被任何东西所左右。艾米莉，我想知道这是否在某种程度上与你的另一项研究有关，该研究着眼于我们在面试中的表现，以及我们在面试中如何判断他人。所以我们都认为，我们可以坐在某人对面半个小时，跟他们谈谈，就能很好地判断这个人
is a good fit for a job. But if someone were to come along and say, oh, we can talk to you for half an hour, and figure out if you are a good fit for the job, we say, that's clearly inadequate because I'm so much more complex than anything that can be ascertained in 30 minutes. Right.
是否适合某个工作岗位。但是，如果有人来对我们说：“哦，我们可以跟你谈半个小时，就能弄清楚你是否适合这份工作，”我们就会说：“这显然是不够的，因为我比任何能在30分钟内查明的事情要复杂得多。”对吧。
So there's a term, the interview illusion, which I did not coin, and it was about this idea that it's an illusion that you can tell so much from an interview. If I want to know whether you're going to be a good brick layer, it's probably a lot more valuable for me to watch you lay bricks and for me to ask your five prior bosses, how well you lay bricks, then for me to sit down and interview you about how good a brick layer you are. And yet people love interviews. And even psychologists, we do job interviews. Why do we do that?
所以有一个术语叫“面试错觉”（the interview illusion），这不是我发明的，它指的是这样一种观点：你能从一次面试中看出那么多东西，这其实是一种错觉。如果我想知道你是否会成为一个优秀的砌砖工，看你砌砖，并向你之前的五位老板询问你砌砖的技术有多好，这可能比我坐下来面试你、问你觉得自己砌砖技术有多好要有价值得多。然而人们就是喜欢面试。甚至连心理学家也会进行工作面试。我们为什么要这样做？
We could just ask the people who've worked with the person, you know, we could ask their advisors to write letters and we could read their work but we do interviews as well and we put a lot of weight on them and the work that I did we actually had people come into the laboratory and pairs these were students who never met each other and they talked to each other for a half an hour and we found that at the end of the half an hour they felt like they'd really come to know the other person but that the other person had not really come to know them so you could only get a small understanding and a small glimpse of who I am from that conversation. But I've got the whole you.
我们本来可以去问那些和这个人共事过的人，你知道的，我们可以请他们的导师写推荐信，我们可以阅读他们的作品，但我们也会进行面试，并且对面试赋予了很大的权重。在我所做的研究中，我们实际上让人们成对来到实验室，这些是互不相识的学生，他们交谈了半小时，我们发现半小时结束时，他们觉得他们真正了解了对方，但对方并没有真正了解他们。所以你只能从那场对话中对我是谁有一个小小的了解和一瞥。但我却拥有一个完整的你。
And part of that has to do with the fact that I know all the stuff about me that you didn't find out from that conversation. I'm aware of all the stuff I didn't say. All the stuff I said that maybe was misleading about who I really am. I've got all that. But I don't have all that about you. You can see how these biases might play out in the context, not just of interpersonal conflict, but geopolitical conflict. If you think you see the world accurately and I don't,
部分原因在于我知道所有关于我自己的事情，而那些是你从那次交谈中没有发现的。我知道所有我没有说的事情。所有我说的可能对我是谁产生误导的话。我拥有这一切。但我没有关于你的所有这些。你可以看到，这些偏见不仅会在人际冲突的背景下发挥作用，还会在地缘政治冲突中发挥作用。如果你认为你准确地看到了世界而我没有，
if you try to set me straight and find you can't change my views, what are you to conclude? The simplest explanation is that I can't be trusted. There's no point trying to understand me, or reason with me, or negotiate with me, because I must be either stupid or evil. It's not just people's actions that influence how we want to respond to them. It's also our beliefs about what those actions stem from, and if we believe that individuals are biased, that their mental processes are biased, then we don't believe that it makes sense to try to reason with them. Is there any evidence that teaching people about
如果你试图让我走上正轨，却发现你无法改变我的观点，你会得出什么结论？最简单的解释就是我是不可信的。试图去理解我、说服我或与我谈判是没有意义的，因为我一定要么是愚蠢的，要么是邪恶的。不仅是人们的行为影响了我们想要如何回应他们，还有我们对这些行为根源的信念——如果我们相信个人是有偏见的，他们的思维过程是有偏见的，那么我们就不会相信试图去说服他们是有意义的。有没有任何证据表明，向人们传授
the ways in which our minds work, that it actually changes the way they can actually perceive the conflict and perhaps respond differently. When people learn about these different biases, they're initially very optimistic that what we need to do is educate people about the biases. So if I just tell people, like my students, here's the different biases that people engage in, that that should solve the problem. They'll say, gee, I didn't know about all those biases. Yeah. And the idea is now that I know about them, I won't do them. But as you know, that's not how it works.
我们大脑运作的方式，真的能改变他们对冲突的看法，并可能做出不同的反应？当人们了解到这些不同的偏见时，他们最初非常乐观地认为，我们需要做的是对人们进行偏见方面的教育。因此，如果我只是告诉人们，比如我的学生：“这里有各种人们会陷入的偏见，”那应该就能解决问题。他们会说：“天哪，我以前不知道所有这些偏见。是的。”他们的想法是，既然我了解了它们，我就不会犯这些错误了。但正如你所知，事情并非如此运作。
Because what happens is they say, gee, I didn't have words for all those biases. But now that you've told me the words, they give me a great vocabulary for describing what all these people around me keep doing. So that doesn't work. That doesn't work. But what not you cooked there, and I tried,
因为发生的情况是，他们会说：“天哪，我以前没有词汇来描述所有这些偏见。但既然你告诉我了这些词，它们为我提供了一个极好的词汇库，用来描述我周围这些人一直在做的事情。”所以这不管用。这不管用。但是你没有做的是，我尝试过的是，
was instead to educate people about the importance of unconscious processes. And we taught people about how a lot of our judgments are rooted in things we don't have access to, so that a lot of things are automatic, and a lot of things are biased. And so we tried to educate them about essentially the introspection illusion,
转而对人们进行关于无意识过程重要性的教育。我们向人们传授我们的许多判断是如何植根于我们无法触及的事物中的，因此很多事情是自动的，很多事情是有偏见的。所以我们试图向他们教育本质上是内省错觉的内容——
the illusion that we have access to all these things, and the fact that instead much of it is occurring automatically and is biased, and then we asked people to complete our usual bias blind spot measure where they read about various biases. And then people no longer showed a bias blind spot. So once they understood about the operation of the unconscious and how these things happen automatically, they no longer claimed to be less biased than others. So then they said, gee, maybe I am biased, maybe looking inwards and not seeing bias
这种我们能够接触到所有这些事物的错觉，以及实际上其中很大一部分是自动发生且带有偏见的这一事实。然后我们要求人们完成我们常规的偏见盲点测量，其中他们阅读了各种偏见。在那之后，人们不再表现出偏见盲点。因此，一旦他们了解了无意识的运作方式以及这些事情是如何自动发生的，他们就不再声称自己比别人更少偏见。所以他们会说：“天哪，也许我确实有偏见，也许向内审视却看不到偏见并不是判断我是否有偏见的最佳方式。”
is not the best way to conclude whether I'm biased or not. Can you give me a concrete example of a time when you used your own research to change how you thought about something important or to change your own behavior. I don't know if I can give you a single important example, but I think that as a parent, I find it happening with me all the time. That, you know, I'm talking to my kids about someone in our lives who's done something that sort of has irritated us in some way. Somebody canceled on a plan that we had or said something that was insensitive. I find myself doing that thing where I'm about to jump to the fundamental attribution or I'm about to say, gee, that was mean or inconsiderate or lazy or whatever, and then
你能给我一个具体的例子吗？关于你何时利用自己的研究来改变你对某件重要事情的看法，或者改变你自己的行为。我不知道能否给你举出一个重大的例子，但我想作为一名父母，我发现这种事一直发生在我身上。你知道的，我和孩子们谈论我们生活中的某个人，那个人做了某种在某种程度上激怒我们的事情。有人取消了我们的计划，或者说了一些不敏感的话。我发现自己正要做那件事——我正要陷入基本归因错误，或者我正要说：“天哪，那太刻薄、太缺乏考虑或者太懒惰了，诸如此类。”然后
I've got my kids there with me. Oh, this is not what I want to teach my children. And so I say, wait a second, you know, I know it might seem like the person was being inconsiderate, but maybe they're having a really hard day. I tried to sort of teach them and to remind myself to think about people's circumstances instead of jumping right away to that dispossitional attribution. You know Emily as I'm thinking about your work, I'm realizing that many miscommunications might happen because our thoughts seem so clear to us, but we do a terrible job communicating those thoughts to others.
我的孩子们就在我身边。哦，这不是我想教给我孩子的东西。所以我说：“等一下，你知道，我知道那个人看起来可能很缺乏考虑，但也许他们今天过得很艰难。”我试图以此教导他们，并提醒自己去思考人们的环境，而不是马上跳到那个性格归因上去。你知道，艾米莉，当我思考你的工作时，我意识到许多沟通不畅的发生，是因为我们的想法对我们自己来说是如此清晰，但在向他人传达这些想法时，我们却做得非常糟糕。
Things in our minds seem so clear and loom so large to us that we somehow assume they must be clear to others as well. Yeah, it's interesting. I think of the example of breakups, romantic breakups, and people sort of they want to be kind and they want to be considerate and they want to do it nicely not always. And the other person is left totally confused. And he's, oh, you know, yeah, I think, you know, we're just taking a break for a few days. We just hit a rough patch. The other person thinks they have successfully broken up and ended their relationship. We forget that our intentions, what we're intending to do is to break up, to close the door,
我们脑海中的事情对我们来说是如此清晰、显得如此重大，以至于我们不知何故假设它们对别人来说也一定同样清晰。是的，这很有趣。我想到了分手的例子，浪漫关系的破裂。人们某种程度上希望表现得善良、体贴，想以一种美好的方式结束——并非总是如此。而另一个人则完全陷入了困惑。他说：“哦，你知道，是的，我想，你知道，我们只是休息几天。我们只是遇到了挫折。”另一个人则认为他们已经成功分手并结束了关系。我们忘记了我们的意图——我们打算做的是分手，是关上这扇门，
but to do it in a very kind and considerate way. The other person thinks is that you've sent a bunch of mixed messages and you're leaving the door open. So this is just one of so many examples where we don't recognize our lack of transparency and what we haven't communicated because it's so obvious to us. I don't know if you're a fan of the show Parks and Recreation, but there was an incident on Parks and Rec
但要以一种非常善良和体贴的方式去做。而另一个人却认为你发出了许多矛盾的信息，并且你正在为对方敞开大门。所以这只是众多例子中的一个，我们没有意识到自己缺乏透明度，也没有意识到我们没有传达出什么，因为这对我们来说太显眼了。我不知道你是否是电视剧《公园与游憩》（Parks and Recreation）的粉丝，但《公园与游憩》中曾发生过这样一幕：
that basically is almost exactly the same line, so one party is breaking up with another, but they break up so politely and so kindly of the other party thinks, great, we've had a wonderful chat, the relationship is now on to a higher level than it was before, and one party thinks they're broken up with the other party things. Wow, we're really on a good place now. So you're leaving soon. Back to Indianapolis briefly, and then on to a town called Snirling Indiana for several months.
基本上台词几乎完全一样，一方与另一方分手，但他们分手得如此礼貌、如此温和，以至于另一方认为：“太棒了，我们有了一次美妙的交谈，现在我们的关系上升到了比以前更高的高度。”而一方认为他们已经分手了，另一方则认为：“哇，我们现在的关系真的处于一个好阶段了。”所以你要不久留了吗？先短暂回到印第安纳波利斯，然后在一个叫印第安纳州斯纳林（Snirling）的小镇呆上几个月。
Never heard of it. It's quite small. The cows at number the people 41. And then after Chris moves and tracks him down, storms into his house and accuses him of cheating on her. God. I'm so sorry, honey. I'm so embarrassed.
没听说过。它非常小。那里的奶牛比人多41头。然后，在克里斯搬走之后，她追踪到了他，冲进他的家中，指责他背叛了她。天哪。我很抱歉，亲爱的。我很尴尬。
I was scared that you were cheating on me. Oh, I'm cheating on you, but I'm also not dating you. We broke up last week. Yeah, I'm laughing, but it's actually sad. I mean, it actually causes a lot of suffering and reality. Yeah, we've just been through a really bruising political year, Emily, and the country as a whole has been very divided. And a lot of people are really asking asking is it possible for us to come together
我害怕你背叛了我。哦，我背叛了你，但我也没在跟你谈恋爱。我们上周就分手了。是的，我在笑，但实际上这很悲哀。我的意思是，在现实中它确实造成了很多痛苦。是的，我们刚刚经历了一个非常伤人的政治年份，艾米莉，整个国家也非常分裂。许多人都在认真地询问：在经历了一场非常痛苦的政治争斗之后，
as a nation after you know very bitter political fight. I'm wondering if you were to give advice to the nation based on the work that you have done what would that advice look and sound like? I mean I think one thing I would say is that if you were judging yourself by all your positive intentions, right, and you're good feelings, you know, if your intentions are that you want the country to be in a better place, that you want people to thrive, don't assume that others intentions are different from your own. And if you put a lot of weight on your intentions, those other intentions would deserve just that same amount of weight.
我们这个国家有可能重新凝聚在一起吗？我想知道，如果你根据你所做的工作给国家提出建议，这个建议会是什么样子的，听起来会是怎样的？我的意思是，我想我会说的一件事是：如果你用你所有的积极意图和良好的感觉来评判自己，你知道的，如果你的意图是希望国家处于一个更好的地方，希望人们繁荣发展，不要假设别人的意图与你不同。如果你对自己的意图赋予了很大的权重，那么其他人的意图也应该得到同样多的权重。
So we owe some charity in judging others' behavior by giving some weight to their intentions, and we should not assume that their intentions are so different from our own. And if we can start with that and start with the charity of trying to find the positive intentions and others, then maybe there is some hope, but it's so hard to do, especially when things are so divided and feel so divided. Psychologist Emily Pronen teaches at Princeton University. Emily, thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
因此，在通过赋予其意图一定权重来评判他人的行为时，我们应该抱有一点宽容，我们不应假设他们的意图与我们自己的有那么大不同。如果我们能从这一点开始，怀着寻找他人积极意图的宽容态度开始，那么也许还有一些希望，但这太难做到了，尤其是当一切都如此分裂、感觉如此分裂的时候。心理学家艾米莉·普罗宁在普林斯顿大学任教。艾米莉，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒（Hidden Brain Media）制作。
Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ani Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is HR specialist Max Lenowitz. When we launched Hidden Brain Media, Max was an onboarding manager at JustWorks, the company that handles our payroll. Max worked closely with us as we were launching our business, and he patiently answered our
我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保罗（Ani Murphy-Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们今天的无名英雄是人力资源专家马克斯·莱诺维茨（Max Lenowitz）。当我们推出《隐藏的大脑传媒》时，马克斯是JustWorks的一名入职经理，这家公司负责处理我们的薪资。在我们开展业务时，马克斯与我们紧密合作，
many questions about how to pay employees and track things like vacation and sick time. His good cheer made a busy time feel less stressful. Thank you Max for helping us to find our feet. For more of our work please be sure to subscribe to our newsletter. Every week we feature interesting research on human behavior and a brain teaser. Plus, we give you a look at what's coming up on both Hidden Brain and our new show My Unsung Hero. You can subscribe at news.hiddenbrain.org. That's N-E-W-S at HiddenBrain.org. Next week in our mind reading series, we look at how many of us underestimate
他耐心地回答了我们关于如何向员工支付薪酬以及追踪假期和病假等事宜的许多问题。他开朗的精神让忙碌的时光感觉压力没那么大。谢谢马克斯帮助我们站稳脚跟。想了解我们的更多作品，请务必订阅我们的简报。每周我们都会刊登关于人类行为的有趣研究和一个脑筋急转弯。此外，我们还会让你先睹为快《隐藏的大脑》和我们的新节目《我的无名英雄》即将推出的内容。你可以在news.hiddenbrain.org订阅。网址是news.hiddenbrain.org。下周在我们的读心术系列中，我们将探讨我们当中的许多人如何低估了
the goodness in human nature. Guess what people aren't entirely selfish economists have to learn that lesson too. People aren't entirely selfish we actually care a lot about others. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
人性的善良。你猜怎么着？人们并不完全是自私的，经济学家也必须吸取这个教训。人们并不完全是自私的，我们实际上非常关心他人。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。回头见。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。